no I was actually because when I first
saw certain Brad pill content kind of
like like I would hear guys be like
women are hard and like like I would
hear the guys like I know I know I know
that's not but then I would look at the
stats and I was like I can't really
complain about I can't really say
they're not right when it's like one out
of four of us has an STD one out of
three of us has had an abortion ninety
percent of us have been on birth control
it's like
you know it you might not have an of but
like in in terms of like women
throughout history you know the average
chick today it's it's it's it's it's sad
but you know I can't even I can't even
fault the guys for it
and psychically they're programmed to
say well what about you and your body
counselor
forget me let's look at the average guy
right
see what I did no no but no I'm going
somewhere with this hold on it's I'll
come back to me
though if the woman is the prize and the
man nobody wants him unless he's like
really popular
you guys can get [__] a lot the boy
he's starting to even if he's a player
he's not dude everyone goes to the woman
like everyone even if she's like mid
everyone DMS her
a lot of Chads don't even get four DMS a
day you know what I mean so I'm like
it's way more dangerous for them to be
sexually liberated than us
you can actually liberate men all you
want to Max it out and who's into the
envelope really and even me when I was
like I'm an okay looking guy at 19.
I had zero DMS so I need zero DMS uh I I
used to like add random people on
Facebook to look more popular so some
girl would be like oh I'll be never
happen
that I got a job never happened and I
make money in sales never happened
dude if a child is having trouble like
me and I wasn't like awkward talking to
them that's just normal
then what's gonna happen with all these
other chat mid guys and stuff like are
they gonna like start a revolution
they're gonna no they're gonna do a
genocide on themselves they're gonna
kill themselves right the purchasing
power for both genders increase so much
but despair depression anxiety
skyrocketed and Men killing themselves
so much now
and they're trying to say it's not that
bad it's not that bad it's capitalism
bro you have an iPhone don't kill
yourself are you kidding I'm like I have
a great life and I don't like going into
the Wilderness because I see beasts and
[__] in this Beast system imagine you're
just a regular guy you must hate it and
let me grab a cigarette hold on wait I'm
[__] leaving content right now right
bro yeah I know you're doing great
guys one in the chat if he's doing great
make sure you like the video
um we have over 2 000 people watching so
let's try to get uh I don't know a
thousand five hundred likes I feel like
that's reasonable it's reasonable uh
blessing says a thousand likes will open
up the chat
um
it pushes me in the algorithm what
like the video because it pushes me in
the algorithm that way I can talk to
Logan Paul your favorite influencers
um the other thing like when I was
getting into red pill content and like
watching it like at first it was it was
really hard for me to watch as a girl
I'm like what do you mean we ain't [__]
but it's like the numbers just back you
guys up so much you can't deny it it's
like throughout most of History women
were like a hundred years ago 85 only 15
of women admitted to premarital sex
fifteen percent a hundred years ago
um and that's not true yeah and so let's
say they're big Liars right women always
lie so let's just double it and say say
it's really 30 you know what they say I
like to double it or whatever okay but
that's still two out of three
that were virgins on their wedding
nights and that was a hundred years ago
and that was actually when um
that that was still like the start of
feminism because feminism really started
like it had like people think it started
in like the 60s but it was really you
you probably know this but it was like a
hundred it was before that so I would
imagine a hundred years earlier it was
last go ahead
I'm a Catholic so I really believe that
Lou Harris jpws were here thousands of
years ago Jezebel's Fierce earrings and
makeup [__] I mean they've been with
us trying to tempt men for the longest
time and before Christianity
it was like they were like raping doing
molesting little boys and little girls
on Temple Pagan's steps and everyone was
a [__] and stuff like that and then
Christianity would when they boomed and
it would go away and then boom and then
you know how it goes like a wave
it's always been here I feel like it's
always like horse Society has always
been here but right now it's the peak
because I actually got it wrong it's not
10 times women are 20 times less horny
than men and they close the gap on
cheating for the first time in history
they're closing the Gap right now
they're about to do it so right now
would be the most accessibility in
recorded history which I don't know
because history is cute and crime is
warped but I do believe this like
[__] end times it's the worst we've
ever seen it and another thing is like
women shouldn't be afraid to go red
because
let's say they were red pill at 17 which
is [__] impossible
what's the byproduct of that
some model woman would keep her
virginity until 24 25 and marry a
billionaire so she wouldn't do only a
hundred thousand dollars she's gonna do
like a million dollars in 10 years she
would get everything and probably even a
chat
should have everything so if women were
red they gained the most from being read
They're getting the most and they think
it's like we want them to be read so
they can [__] cook and clean and [__]
like that dude they're it's like uh when
Myron said on the show
you haven't met your man and you're 26.
did you have a better chance of meeting
your husband at 22 or 26. and I was like
dude
women need to at 22 they should be
locking up that man like these men are
like since they fall in love so quick
it's very easy to do but they're like
I'll do it after the only kind of stuff
and it's like no no that's when the
waves of competition enters that's very
dangerous to do and then you look at men
like me in a suit and tie at 35
I'll have even more women than right now
you know my value don't change well it
just goes up
and do you feel like you're always red
pill or did you have like a red pill
moment
uh they're telling you that they're
telling you to move closer to the mic
that's what they're saying okay
I feel like yeah I used to get suspended
in elementary school because I could not
imagine a woman playing a video game so
anytime
and anytime I play an MMO and I have a
girlfriend in the MMO I would never
assume it's a man I
mean I would assume it's a man I'd be
like oh it's a dude right because I
couldn't fathom that a woman knows what
maple story or World of Warcraft or
something like that they don't they just
like armies and stuff so I was always
really like sexist like that in my head
or sexist
but I wasn't vocal I was like a quiet
kid and then when I got in the dating
world I tried the equality thing and uh
you know that's how I lost like the
first love of my life I was like whoa
they get so aggressive when they have
leverage but when they're under you
they're just like John let's get ice
cream and [__]
and uh
and yeah when I was like the most toxic
masculine in my city like 22 years old
23 24. I had all the women and I was
like just like some dude on a couch
selling drugs
so I was like wow the missing variable
has to because these are models I'm
working with veterans good looking guys
six four Jack guys uh but I was taking
all the women and the only thing I was
known as a drug dealer
everyone in my city was like that's the
most sexiest guy I had like the worst
worst [__] but I had all the girls and
the guys never copied me they were so
they're still so afraid of women then I
got on Twitch and there's people with
millions of followers and I'm cooking
them at parties
so I was like you know I don't really
think I'm sexist and even if I didn't
believe any of this [__] let's say I
wasn't like biblical or any of that
I don't think I'll change because I
would lose 500 women in my life if I
became anything softer than this version
and this is the softest version I used
to be way worse so I'm like
do people really think
I'm just getting lucky there's so many
Chads with million followers who don't
do what I do they can never do any of
this stuff even the funny ones
I think the missing variable is when
when masculinity is scarce toxic
masculinity is the greatest magnet to
the woman and I went on that show
freshman
yeah
that Canadian girl said I would never
date someone like you you're this you're
that and totally embarrassed me and I
called her a [__] for three hours
straight and then she's in my bed
lingerie
right
no okay I noticed that at shows actually
when I would when I would um like do the
shows in London
um the the feminists that would like be
arguing with the guy after that always
try to sleep with them like it would
happen every single time and that's why
I was like you guys were just like going
at each other now you're trying to go
home with like I don't know
yeah and I I I've asked a lot of girls
in the more intimate settings where they
can be honest and they've all kind of
said the same answer where it's like as
much as I hate what you talk about I
feel safe around you the other people
like those same to Google guys they feel
like those guys are gonna do something
to them in the hotel room and stuff
and uh because if someone's just being
unapologetically honest he's more
trustful well and like a lot of the blue
pill like I realized like so many guys
just lie they just Pander and they just
simply what
you're saying Destiny I did not say any
names
you know it's funny I wasn't even
thinking of Destiny um I was more
thinking of like guys on my show that
they've literally argued they don't care
about body count and I'm just like you
guys are just saying that so you can
sleep with the girls on the show it's so
disingenuous like I know what they're
doing and I and I don't like it because
it's not honest it's like you know that
if you when you're looking like because
it's like younger guys in their 20s
they're like oh I don't care but they're
not looking for a wife
yeah
and and you're talking about like go for
a hookup all right like I'm about to sin
if I said on a show the girls to sleep
on the first date are [__] skanks
they'd call me my hotel and be like oh
we're not sleeping this is our first
date because they heard it on the show
and I'd be like okay that's not how this
works you gotta leave my hotel right now
but now I know why guys lie because they
go they don't want that where she's like
blue balls them and just cuddles them so
they go hey I don't care about your body
count just take your clothes off and
[__]
but uh if I do any Pony [__] I don't
even get hard I don't get aroused I'd be
like I need to be John zurka if I'm
gonna sleep with the girl if I feel like
I'm watered down zerkuk I'm an auto
sexual it's weird I know but like I turn
myself on so if it's on Circa in the
room with the girl it's way less hard
for me way less hard if it's circus
saying what up [__]
then I just can be myself and like I
don't feel like the government's gonna
come take take me away I don't know this
is weird well I also think that like
some guys will say they don't care
because in there had women lie anyway so
they'll never know
yeah which I I think is a cope I think
they'll figure it out eventually to like
that's that's why if they're
but like I think women tend to tell on
themselves in the long run
um I don't think any man could do like a
year and a half of celibacy anymore when
I did that the year flew by so I was
like oh my God I didn't I didn't I
wasn't like you every month I gotta push
harder and it was easy like a year and a
half just flew by and I was just busy in
my work and I read books and I did all
this right
um and then I read even more when I had
a girlfriend because I felt that urge
when the lockdowns were over that you
know I've been cooped up I need to do
some social things because I already
suffered from anti-social personality
disorder it actually damaged my career
because I wouldn't collaborate with
anyone for years just make money alone
so when I got out in the world I'm like
oh I'm about to be a hoe you know
because I'm impatient I'm not gonna like
wait for the right girl so I just picked
my favorite girl who's anti-vaxx and got
banned for that Maga and I was like
let's go travel and if I have one
girlfriend
I don't cheat like I know I know who I
am it's very easy for me and so all that
extra energy I just put into books and
stuff but if I had multiple women I
would have never read these books I
wouldn't be in this position in this
hotel none of that and so I played the
game smart like really smart and that's
why that's where Myron and I disagree
the most is like he tells Ben to have
like four girlfriends I think men are
their best that they have one and zeros
how you make a billion dollars but you
know you still need to you don't want to
waste your youth you know you still want
to find the girl right this was an
Einstein a virgin
no he [__] this cousin
Oh I thought I thought there was some
guy that was a famous virgin but I don't
remember I thought it was Einstein you
think you have Nick Fuentes who made a
million dollars and did you still don't
think about women he just wants his
movement to grow and it's such like a
like men don't realize having an army
and being a general is way better than
sex
sex you can have for the rest of your
life like that'll come but uh yeah
actually watching Nick is why I went
sober for like a year and a half
and because I I know that that energy if
you're not dating where does it have to
go you think oh am I gonna die alone no
I'm gonna have an Empire and then women
will want me and I'll be safe from
despair because I can choose pick and
choose and if you build a big enough
Empire you can even have a virgin maybe
you have to go into a Hut like
I actually I almost think that like
the way women are today makes it harder
for virgins too because like how does
the men gonna know if she is
yeah I mean like I've heard guys I've
heard of that guy say that like girls
will even lie about that like say
they're virgin
yeah yeah like girls lie about a lot
when it comes to dating they lie a lot
because the whole the whole world's
pointing at them saying they [__] up
and they're always but uh the
interesting thing is nobody understands
that the biggest turn off for a girl is
if you don't know how to like put a
condom on or you're like sexually
inexperienced and that translates to
every part of the relationship so a
virgin has a bunch of trouble unless he
knows their nature like there's only one
virgin who gets it it's Nick like he
dick has beautiful women dming him and
or they try and get on his podcast to
win and move over like these neocon type
girls and uh he understands women
because he's so intelligent but nobody
has that kids like you so all these
virgins are kind of [__] you know and
they really need to focus on the Trinity
uh in of dating which is you know their
looks and hygiene their Network the most
important one
and um
no no I actually I know one who I I
believe I like I think she's a virgin
like I believe it I know another girl
that I know a couple girls that waited
till they were married from like my high
school they're very Catholic
um but are they happy yeah I think so
um I haven't talked to them in a bit but
the one like she's um
she's been married for like three four
years now
um she's kid marriage is considered like
some kind of like Lucid topic no that's
the end game of life it's like dude
growing old alone
I hate saying this but your parents
won't be around your siblings will be
with their people you will be alone even
if you have family friends you'll be
you'll have that feeling of alone
sometimes especially if you don't have a
purpose in life but women don't
understand and men that like marriage is
end game it's not career career is the
bridge to marriage marriage is
everything marriage is if marriage
wasn't in the Bible I wouldn't take it
serious but uh yeah when I was like wow
this book actually figured out how
humans have to like coexist but the
marriage is everything you know
uh so tell me about what
all right I'm gonna ask you about this
I'm trying to be respectful so how
Dustin just hit me I'm not I'm not gonna
cry no no not you not you Destiny what
happened weren't you guys friends now
you're not like I just I saw a tweet of
his today
I had a conversation with his wife when
she was at sneakos and I'm like look man
it's been probably like months and
months of me like I've always Juiced
this channel every time he's called me
on I'll go and it's not like I grow with
the liberal audience I go there for like
conversations and it's fun you know it's
good banter but really it's a chore too
right and
really it's like if I leak the DMS
there's 35 Plus DMS where he just leaves
me on red and then when he needs me I
just always go and you know it's been
like this for years but
I always I always thought of it as he's
edgy I'm edgy so I want to be around
this guy Manny does this thing to Nick
where like he just pretends he has a
reason that karamati didn't he just
juice Nick and then Juiced his content
with Nick and then you know he knew
exactly when to exit very political move
and then he pretended like oh there's
like no he's actually a bad guy and
stuff so when he did it to Nick and he
still wouldn't collaborate with Nick
even when I'm talking to Nick it's like
it would have been the greatest collabs
of us all together everyone wants it
wouldn't do it backed out of the debate
with uh me Nick on politically provoked
and
then he just like says something about
circus going through it like he's having
a crackhead moment so I'll come back to
him later I'm like that's not how it
works bro like it's if I leak these DMs
I would look like this off the sweetest
sweetheart on Earth and I would go with
all the memes of shikachu on no jumper
it's not true I just say it because it's
like he would have he's a nice guy he
would have actually got me that connect
so I was like if he would do it I'll
just say he did but really I had the
email months in advance even the
producer of no jumper and stuff were
like no he didn't get you on but uh you
know I would just protect his reputation
and say yo he has great relationships
with women who are trying to kill him
and cancel them you know how would you
protect him from Mr girl everyone who
attacked him and
yeah and then when I saw he did that all
that stuff to Nick and he's doing it to
me still I'm like this is kind of gay
plus he's a red pill Orbiter attacking
my whole movement I'm like this is like
the most one-sided abusive relationship
I've ever been a part of
and I'm not really an Orbiter you know
I'm Circa I'm bigger than him so it's
like dude you know from a business
perspective he looks like a [__] too
so I was like all right and he's always
let his community just like call me her
rapist and weird [__] like that or like
evil [__] but recently I saw all the
commas 72 000 views on a YouTube video
and they're all [__] on me
pretending like he's the good guy in
this friendship
when the for years they've been saying
Circle has been so good to you so loyal
yeah there's Clips the best he said for
four years I never had a problem with
zerka uh either we've never had a
problem but I'm I was way too good to
that guy and being around sneak on these
people made me realize like
am I nicer to Steve than snico
and there's something [__] I have like
uh Stockholm syndrome with that [__]
loser so I said [__] it if the whole
chat's gonna [__] on me and he's
promoting it he's not even saying now
zerka's a cool dude that guy's a [__]
snake like what the [__] but I don't
want to say snake like I take it
personal if I saw him on the street I'd
say hey but definitely it's like kind of
gay for me to be involved in that kind
of relationship when there's people who
bust ass for me like real friends
and and when you weigh it I've done way
more for that guy than he has done for
me but no one will ever see it because
he's the bigger Channel which is so
stupid because when I'm the bigger
Channel what do you think I'm going to
abandon him how do I help the [__] out
of him just like I shouldn't be fighting
Mr girl from him but I do it anyway so
what's Mr girl I don't actually know
what happened
he's like some pedal that Destiny would
defend in his community and then he
turned on him and tried to make Destiny
uh sexual abuser and I defended him even
though I didn't talk to Stephen for
months
and uh yeah I just instinctively always
defended him and then now it's kind of
like
even if he was in my life
dude there's people like kill Mike and
sneagles who do so much for me that it's
like I wouldn't really waste my time
with Steve and I was offering I was like
Steve I want to come straight drops we
do content and he's always like when I
went through the hill Mike house he does
a [__] hit piece on me it's just uh
you being used by heal Mike and stuff
basically it's like I'm not juicing his
Channel with krantos and all those other
[__] losers he stays with he's with
Phil Mike but he'll mind's giving me a
bunch of crypto money and bringing me
the investors and like all this good
stuff so I'm like damn bro this guy's
actually Clueless
but yeah that's the last time I want to
talk about that because uh really
Destiny's not a bad guy he's just a
businessman
but he's a stupid businessman right he's
like literally stupid it's uh I'm
I'm the money as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible